استخدم نتنياهو قصة المدينة المنورة هذه
الفلسطينية كنوع من الحملة السياسية لا بد لي من ذلك
إخبارك بنجاح كبير كان أمرًا سعيدًا لأنه
نعلم جميعًا أجزاء كبيرة جدًا من الولاية
إسرائيل ربما تعارض غالبية الجمهور في دولة إسرائيل ذلك
من أجل دولة فلسطينية وليس سرا إلا أن نقول
هذه الأشياء باللغة الإنجليزية لرئيس الولايات المتحدة
إن قول كلمة "لا" أصعب بكثير وتحديًا
اطلبوا دولة فلسطينية لم يقلها وهذا واضح
قبلة رئيس الوزراء لا تنفي تلك الدول
التحالف لا يتطلب ذلك حتى لو بقيت
هذه الأشياء في صوته وهي أكثر سيسا
سياسيا عندما يتكلم تمار فوق رأس
نتنياهو مباشرة للجمهور الأمريكي الإسرائيلي
نحن نقدم لك خطة الحلم
تقول الأحلام أنك سوف تحصل على تغييرات كبيرة الآن
سوف تدفع في وقت ما في المستقبل ما هي التغييرات
التطبيع الكامل مع الحاخام السعودي وستة
والدول الإسلامية بالإضافة إلى ذلك مظلة أمنية
ومن غير المسبوق أن تتمكن إسرائيل من أخذ أي شيء منه
سوف تدفع في بيان النوايا الذي سيؤدي إلى مخطط تفصيلي
في مرحلة ما في المستقبل بالنسبة للدولة الفلسطينية متى
ستكون هذه الدولة دولة منزوعة السلاح بدون جيشها الخاص
نفسها بحيث يخترع الأمريكيون بالفعل للجمهور
الإسرائيليون لأنهم يفهمون أن نتنياهو ليس شريكاً حينها
بادئ ذي بدء، ينبغي أن يقال أن كل شيء متصل
وأيضا لمسألة اليوم التالي والدولة الفلسطينية
وادعاء أو افتراض إدارة بايدن أنه لو كان رئيسا
وربما كانت حكومة أخرى تمتلك حبلاً أكثر اتساعاً في الأفق
حكومة مختلفة ومع ائتلاف مختلف أولاً وقبل كل شيء
من المؤكد أن الدولة الفلسطينية لن تخرج من هذا الوضع
ليس في الفترة المقبلة، وبالتأكيد ليس طالما
إن الرفاهية العامة في إسرائيل هي ما نراه
في استطلاعات الرأي، أريد أيضًا أن أقول ما إذا كان غانتس سيدرك ذلك
كانت الانتخابات وتولي منصب رئيس الوزراء صعبة بالنسبة له
ومن الصعب للغاية أن نقول لرئيس أميركي إجابة مختلفة عن ذلك
التي يقدمها نتنياهو وهي في الواقع دولة فلسطينية
فرصتها في النهوض ليست كبيرة بالنسبة لآرييل
اشترِ حيث تهب الرياح بهذه الأشياء
وترى ماغي هنا نفس مناورة نتنياهو التي أقوم بها أنا
يجب أن أقول أنه كان يفعل ذلك لمدة 15 عاما، وهذا هو من
خطاب بريان بأنه يقول نعم للدولة الفلسطينية
لكنه يضع مثل هذه السلسلة اللطيفة التي تصبح
كما قال المرسل ديفيد فريدمان ذات مرة
يجعلها دولة على القمر الآن على ما أعتقد
وهناك إنجاز هنا عندما يقول بايدن دولة فلسطينية
بدون جيش يبدأ في الاقتراب من المواقع الإسرائيلية
وهي في الواقع اقتربت من مواقف نتنياهو في ذلك الوقت
ويقول إن نتنياهو يتلاعب هنا بلا شك، ويلعب هنا لعبة
يقضي الزعيم السياسي الآن هذه الليلة ليس من أجل البلاد
الفلسطيني يخبر باين بشيء يفتخر به
منه، نعم، إلى الدولة الفلسطينية، يمكنك القول
هناك نوع من اللعبة التي يلعبها نتنياهو مع الرئيس
الولايات المتحدة، ولكن في النهاية عليك أن تقول أنت أيضًا
الشيء الواضح ويجب نقله إلى رشفة
للأميركيين وعندما يقول تهديدات يقولون الجمل
إنه أمر خطير لا يمكن أن يحدث إلا للدولة الفلسطينية
وعلينا أيضا أن نضمن أمن إسرائيل
لنقول لهم آسف جدا هذا البيان
لا أقول أفضل صديق في العالم هو
كلام خطير يجب ألا تعرفه الدولة الفلسطينية
يمكن أن تنشأ عندما يقولون دولة فلسطينية بدونها
وعلى الجيش أن يفهم هذا الأمر في النهاية
من شيء
أوه لا يمكنك أن تتراجع عن الانفراج إلا إذا
لديك السيطرة الأمنية كما نفعل
ونحن نفعل اليوم في مناطق شمرون اليهودية ما نفعله
إنهم يعتزمون أن يفعلوا ذلك في قطاع غزة، والآن لا تفعل ذلك
يمكن القيام بذلك عندما يكون هناك كيان محدد
ولذلك فإن هذا الأمر غير مقبول على الإطلاق كدولة
الممكن ليس مستحيلاً فحسب، بل هو مسألة منطقية
يفهم المرء
وهو ما يشكل خطراً على وجود الدولة التي هي في الواقع أقاليم
ما نزيله هو أساس للعدوان المضاد
وتشعر دولة إسرائيل أيضًا أن يزناق هو في الواقع غانتس
لصالح السلطة الفلسطينية
وبعد ذلك اتخذت القرار بشأن الاتحاد بين
الأزرق والأبيض لأمل جديد كان اتفاقا بيننا
ومن الواضح أن هناك ورقة سياسية مفصلة هي جزء منها
معارضة إقامة دولة فلسطينية